707 is fully engulfed I can't get in
there's a three-year-old in back bedroom
s
back bedroom I try to smash out the
window
hello
[Music]
police anyone in there buddy come on man
what's the kid's name
[Music]
what's the kid's name MJ MJ
Michael
hey back up get out of here back up can
you hear me MJ MJ can you hear me MJ
come on buddy MJ it's the police it's
okay buddy come on
[Music]
come on
[Music]
hey you're right here buddy
thank you
[Applause]
back up
did you get him he's right here is he
down or what he's right there he's right
now come on come here come here buddy
think about that
yeah
he's right
here
you're gonna do it do it now come on
come on
[Music]
right there to your right
we got it here
foreign
[Music]
I don't know where he went
away
he's trying to get them right now
[Music]
get up there get up there get up there
I got oh my God
perfect
that's right
this way watch the holes watch your
holes
you okay buddy
Daddy's crying
[Music]
[Music]
he was just crying
clear up
his name is MJ Michael James or
something like that three years old
he's in the back bedroom yeah
in that one yeah but the other one was
on fire yeah
stay in there yep yep
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you think
[Music]
472 please
there now
you okay yeah that's it baby that's it
Mama come on Mama
come on
come on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
she got it she breathing
huh okay
was she eating anything no she haven't
eaten anything she's been sick
while I'm trying to get in position
alive
ah
Lord I love you thank you
[Music]
over here over here
[Music]
immediately what kind of status we have
uh health condition yes no invisible
scrape marks no
uh she's a child that confirmed the
leopard shorts and uh purple gel shoes
tell them to let me talk
[Music]
prepare to receive go
sh
about
40 yards
she's wearing the clothes that were
described
leopard print bottoms and a white
T-shirt
[Music]
this way
[Music]
come this Parker Parker Parker
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
good job guys
[Music]
remember how we got back here
[Music]
don't look like a child
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay
you know where she was exactly
um I don't know the location I just know
that if you uh if you when we were on
the line yeah we kept going straight and
there's a fenced area like with up to
here okay and we just kept going going
and she would pass it to you I know
where it's at if I if I go man I
actually got to go back here
let's see what I'm doing
y'all they didn't see anything else
around me right it's just for a walker
it was just her she was hiding behind
the bushes
we heard her because she started crying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
assistant
1897.
00
[Music]
I got the baby breathing
hey hey hey hey
guys hey hey
I got